le voy a contar un poco mi historia y un
poco quién son y de dónde vengo
el hospitalito de fondo aire emoción
libertad
eso sentía cuando me juntaba a jugar al
fútbol ahí en una de las canchas del
barrio y lo único que importaba era
ganar porque si
admito que toda la vida fui bastante
competitivo y orgulloso
en este barrio donde el fútbol lo era
todo
se llamaba el aviso 15 o se oculta
ese fue el nombre que le pusieron donde
no quería que se notara la pobreza la
necesidad la ciudad fea
les cuento que cuando yo tenía 5 años de
edad
mi mamá y mi papá se separaron y
terminaron su relación bastante mal
entonces con mi mamá y mi hermano nos
mudamos a la villa donde ya estaba mi
abuela
en ese momento mi infancia fue muy
difícil
me apoyaba mucho en el colegio pero
volver a casa no era mejor vivía en una
habitación super chiquitita con mi mamá
y mi hermano y muchas veces no teníamos
para comer pero sin embargo seguimos
subsistiendo
y si bien el fútbol me encantaba como el
freestyle y el rap del barrio hoy en día
y fue la invasión
a mi mamá ese ambiente mucho no le
gustaba
un tiempo más tarde
recuerdo que cuando estábamos en la
secundaria mi familia
no tenía fondos y estábamos muy mal
económicamente
entonces recuerdo que yo no pude ir algo
esterilizados pero sin embargo
la pareja de mi mamá mi padrastro en ese
momento
me regale una computadora
esa computadora mi primer computadora
sin saberlo
me va a llevar a conocer
un mundo infinito de saberes y me va a
abrir las puertas a muchas oportunidades
ya muchos sueños
cuando yo terminé la secundaria
empiezo a buscar trabajo y pude
conseguir para trabajar en una
metalúrgica como cadete
tenía que levantar el eje de 100 kilos
bolsas de material todo el día
y cuando estaba en la metalúrgica
recuerdo que conoce un ruso que se
llamaba en la vida
esa persona me llamó mucho la atención
de él su orden
una cosa que otra cosa que otra cosa que
otra cosa hecha en una persona realmente
admirable con su orden en ese momento
mi jefe de la metalúrgica era jose y
siempre que jose tenía un problema con
las computadoras sobre sistemas me pedía
ayuda para poder arreglarlo pero ya de
computadoras sin sistemas no sabía
absolutamente nada
y a mí sin embargo me dio garcía
investigar
y aprender a solucionar esos problemas
cuando después de un tiempo de trabajar
en la metalúrgica
tuve la suerte de irme a ver con mi
abuelo lucio
de san justo
creado de familia italiana
y bien a la antigua y nuestras vidas con
él
mi abuelo me enseñó a ser una persona
ordenada y organizada y también me contó
muchas historias de vida
sobre todo el esfuerzo y sacrificio que
él hizo
y mientras yo vivía con mi abuelo
tomé la decisión del clima en la
universidad y también fue cuando empecé
mi segundo trabajo en una cadena de
supermercados
si él estaría en la universidad duro tan
sólo tres o cuatro meses la realidad de
ese momento me hizo tener que elegir
entre el trabajo y el estudio
y tuve que elegir trabajar
y mientras yo estaba trabajando en el
supermercado sentido trabajar como
repositor el pibe se acomodaba las papas
fritas la mermelada limpiaba los pisos
después de a poco
y empezando a trabajar como cajero su
día ya estaba trabajando como cajero y
me llamaron de la oficina central me
llamaron de la oficina central a mí
ezequiel no lo podía creer o sea me
llamaron para ofrecer un trabajo mejor
si bien estaba muy angustiado por no
haber podido continuar en la universidad
cuando me llamaron me preguntaron si me
interesaba aprender de computadoras y de
computación y yo les dije que sí que me
gustaba investigar
y bueno empecé a trabajar en ese lugar
en las oficinas
después de elaborar en este lugar unos
años al centro de la empresa
la empresa tenía solamente 30 tiendas
y unos años más tarde la empresa ya
tenía 900 tiendas de los cuales yo había
participado de armar las máquinas y los
sistemas de al menos unas 300 tiendas
en ese lugar conocí muchos compañeros y
grandes amigos de los cuales aprendí
mucho como walter héctor
no me los voy a olvidar nunca
y un día después de seis años y medio de
trabajar en este lugar
un amigo me miró con una
propuesta laboral mejor pero era muy
difícil
tomar la decisión en ese momento
porque si usted va en un lugar
como dos conocidos donde ya conocía todo
el mundo
pero sin embargo
las ganas de aprender algo nuevo y la
curiosidad me ganaron y terminé
aceptando este trabajo
y ahí
empecé a trabajar en una empresa de
telecomunicaciones
y en ese lugar era realmente
sorprendente un compañero llamado a mano
siempre con la gente con la simpleza de
recomendarme el un manual o un artículo
hizo que un nuevo mundo se abría ante mí
el mundo de leer aprender e implementar
así de manera infinita
les cuento que en este lugar trabajé
tres años y un día el día para que otro
la empresa empezó a pasar por una
situación en cada uno ubicación por
difícil y empezaron a echar gente todos
los días los echamos día de mañana 4
mañana 5 mañana se y me quemé dijo en
ese momento hoy tengo que echar a uno si
quiere yo le dije examen y yo seguir más
joven
lo hice para cubrir a mis amigos también
ya mi compañero
y admito que si bien esta fue una
decisión difícil
eso me permitió con la indemnización
poder comprar un servidor
donde ahí aprendí
empecé a aprender la misma cosa que
aprendía en el trabajo pero en mi casa
y ahí en ese momento fue cuando empecé a
aprender un poco cómo funcionaba todo si
yo estudiaba más
aprendía nuevos temas se aprendía los
dos temas podía certificar los mismos sé
que no es igual en todos los trabajos
pero en el mundo de los sistemas es así
y esto me permitió a mí poder tener
nuevas oportunidades laborales siempre
para poder seguir creciendo y
aprendiendo
siempre
y mucho más importantes y desafiantes a
nivel proyecto
les cuento que hoy en día soy ingeniero
de box boxing señor le dice para lo que
no sabes lo que es
es un ingeniero que tiene conocimientos
en casi todas las áreas de los sistemas
y en casi todas las tecnologías
y ese mismo título fue el que me
permitió poder entrar a trabajar en una
de las empresas más importantes del
mundo y de mi vida
y en uno de los lugares donde más
aprendí lo conocía a la gallega ya
muchísimos amigos
y ahora yo le quería preguntar alguna
vez alguien pidió algo por una
aplicación comida o delivery por una
aplicación
supongo que si no bueno esa aplicación
la aplicación de delivery más importante
y grande de latinoamérica
yo y una de las personas que dicen que
esa aplicación cuando en la empresa
solamente alrededor de 50
personas
y las condiciones para entrar a trabajar
en ese lugar en ese momento era darlo
todo y eso fue lo que hice y todo y mi
máximo esfuerzo
y un día después de un tiempo
empecé a soñar con la posibilidad de ir
a trabajar a la silicon valley el lugar
donde vienen aquí están los ingenieros
más importantes del mundo los ingenieros
que diseñaron los celulares los crearon
nos sirve que nosotros usamos
pero ir a trabajar este lugar no iba a
ser algo fácil yo no sabía nada de
inglés no podía decir hola fellows nada
y para poder seguir priorizando
tenía que seguir estudiando tenía que
aprender inglés tenía que aprender
nuevas tecnologías y eso fue lo que hice
empecé a estudiar inglés
para practicar empieza a tomar
entrevistas de más de 100 entrevistas
cién empresa esta dolencia que no no no
tendencias supermario son muy buenos
técnicamente pero no te puedes comunicar
no no
todo
pero sin embargo
no nunca me rendí siempre
seguí insistiendo
hasta que un día cuando ya estaba muy
cansado en por rendirme una empresa me
dijo sí y tuve la oportunidad de ir a
trabajar a california con gente
realmente increíble
en una empresa que se dedica a la
innovación en la tecnología en la salud
y la ciencia algo realmente importante
y trabajar en este lugar me permitió
que en pocos meses
nuestra aplicación
de la industria del bario te fuera un
caso de éxito a nivel mundial y fuera
premiada
a veces
pienso en todo lo que crecí todo lo que
aprendí toda la gente que me ayudó
toda la gente que me acompañó y si me
hace un nudo en la garganta
y a la vez
mucha gente me pregunta
como existe para llegar hasta acá desde
la villa
y yo les digo que fue paso a paso que no
fue fácil requiriendo mucho estudio de
concentración y esfuerzo
pero sin embargo es imposible poder
lograrlo
y a la vez cuando se lo digo de eso
mucha gente más responden pero es
imposible hacer esto que vos hace yo no
entiendo nada
y ahí es donde creo que se equivocan y
es donde principalmente quiero poner en
foco
si lleva tiempo si requiere esfuerzo en
concentración si puede parecer muy
lejano cuando empezás muy muy lejano
pero el mundo de los sistemas y la
tecnología
es un mundo de grandes oportunidades
y hoy en día estoy seguro que por
muchísimos años más la tecnología va a
ser muy importante para el desarrollo de
nuestras vidas y de nuestro futuro
y de la ciencia y de la salud
y para poder lograrlo es muy importante
poder dar internet computadoras enseñar
tecnologías en etapas tempranas lenguaje
de programación para poder darle trabajo
a muchos chicos y a muchas personas
y que ellos tengan la posibilidad de
poder elegir probar y cambiar
y que puedan tener oportunidades una o
varias en este país en este lugar o en
cualquier otro lugar del mundo de
repente las distancias se acortan y las
oportunidades se amplían de manera
inmensa y como ves de repente ya no
importa dónde naciste donde creciste
dónde te criaste cuál es tu fuerte de
pelo o cómo te vestís si me vieran la
mayoría de los días que hizo trabajo
estoy en pijama como hoy pero lo que
realmente importa
es la gana que uno tiene de aprender y
absorber la información de todo lo que
está al alcance de nuestras manos
de nuestros teléfonos o de nuestra
computadora
y si al principio las cosas no funcionan
no se preocupen por lo que no por lo que
realmente importa es que si uno tiene
ganas de hacer algo uno tiene curiosidad
por algo
ese algo lo sientan cuando lo hagan los
sientan y los disfruten como si fuera la
final de un partido de fútbol
la final de la copa del mundo o sea
darlo todo
esforzarse al máximo dar el máximo
sacrificio
porque un día sin saberlo y sin darse
cuenta
todo esto y su esfuerzo les puede
cambiar la vida para siempre
gracias